alright hey Chris the quarantine they
won't let you have the house to see a
barber nothing huh now dude I got
[ __ ] nothing going on I got not well
no next week starting next week my boy
step 4 now shadow pronounced hair so I'm
throw out the Bayridge he's gonna start
doing haircuts he legally out of his
garage so you know it's like he just
blew his cover I feel like that is over
now oh yeah alright out listen you you
did I said hello to you and you you you
got you started kissing the mic which is
inappropriate yeah cuz let me tell you
something I'm [ __ ] horny right now
yeah and I'm looking at those ankles and
Brendan's me and I want to get some
coconut peanut butter on that look that
off alright well I don't even know what
coconut peanut butter is man you gotta
calm down any any brave ladies in New
York willing to come over and hang out
no it's nothing that just a bunch of
dudes so far it's no there's been
nothing no I've been I've been you know
just kind of dude I mean look at this
last time I came on your show in the
beginning of March you know Brian's like
listen guy you know great stories just
gonna be huge for you I see big things
in the future there the pandemic hit so
now I'm doing [ __ ] zoom calls for my
daughter's bedroom I know it's not baby
listen this is throwing us off for a
little bit of a [ __ ] loop sometimes
you get thrown for a loop sometimes you
you get you know what I mean they go you
got to make a left down here and wait
you got to sit in this holding pattern
I'm about the a cup we're all about to
take off our bottoms to express sprout
wings and now we got to sit in the
[ __ ] holding norc's bad huh Chris New
York is really it's actually really bad
I feel like in LA I mean I know you guys
got cases but I mean New York you know
everyone's dying you know and all people
guys yeah what a lot of people died and
it's crazy yep because like you can't
you know I know you guys are doing well
with your you know podcasts and your you
know and everything but like in New York
you know you couldn't pay me enough to
get in the same room as a Chinese and I
know you guys are in there with an Asian
Chris you can't look like I gotta just
be very cat is from Vietnam and and and
cheers is is of South Korea Jumeirah
Tiny's I know but you said Asian and now
you said you wouldn't be a room with 280
loser
a little racist dude so I'm gonna have
to but you would get a little nervous
Chris why is that racist I mean I don't
want to get the [ __ ] wool hand Weiser
all right that's Chinese people from
blue hands god damn it Chris please
don't look at all Asian I think guy I
don't [ __ ] know man I'll just you
know I'll just take a beef or broccoli
what do you let me tell you that's not I
don't know I don't know what I wanted to
tell you that not to be so stereotypical
it's important at these times to
understand that viruses don't
discriminate you know what I'm saying
well ya know what what do you do
I mean honestly man you know I got I got
my daughter I got a four-year-old
daughter so it's everyday it's just done
like preschool stuff with her I do my
podcast I got my podcast history of
hyenas I do our every morning I'm doing
a morning show called what by in the
morning on our patreon patron calm slash
Bay Ridge Boys myself and yon is Papa
Johnny the Greek we've been doing that
every day talking about the stories and
you know that's what I do and I try to
go for a jog but I'm getting fat I
unfortunately um Chrissy cusps I'm right
on the cusp of getting hit my tits back
I'm trying it's just they're they're
starting to fluff up a little bit and I
got a fat fat ass I got a fat lunchlady
ass with fat thighs it's hard not again
it's hard not to eat a lot yeah man
eating and just sitting around in New
York I mean it's scary cuz everybody
everybody knows somebody who's sick or
died it's like 9/11 in New York where
everybody needs somebody and that was
only 3,000 people not only that was
3,000 people this is 1520 thousand
deaths in New York so it gets to the
point where you're just like I mean what
what am i doing well every day all I do
is I put off my gloves my mask and I
wrap myself in the American flag and I
walk outside and I'm protected okay but
I don't know about the American flag I I
appreciate your patriotism I have a very
important question before we get to
patriotism the American flag
your daughter's four years old you're in
a room is there a reason you painted her
wall a bad wing there's a bat wing it
splits bat wing blocking out the light
it's bad like no oh wait there's a bat
wing well below you
oh no because that's that's the
construction that's just the UM we did
like a chalk like a soft wing for her
room so
I [ __ ] up wait let me let me see what
are you guys talking about exactly
hey hey Chris Chris you know we're
[ __ ] pants and you tucked your dog
that looks out that way you gotta you
that a month a man [ __ ]
I got a but yeah I I just wanted to see
what you guys meant it's uh that wasn't
appropriate dude nobody asked you to do
that what dude I can't have a [ __ ] for
quarantine I know you can i I've been
telling Brian for weeks now this
quarantine to make me real gay dude yeah
guy I want to crawl through the [ __ ]
hole in your jeans and go to town you
scrotum you [ __ ] homo Hey well
alright that's aggressive to your your
little love to change right now I need
you to calm man you're coming in hot
Chris gets on Christie quarantine I'm
cooped up Chrissy kind of just hung up
for this [ __ ] already hey can you still
order delicious New York food or are
they shut down - no absolutely can order
you could order a [ __ ] order delicious
food you know and then I they just can't
come within 60 to your door so I got
like a little rake hook and then they
they call me on outside and they come to
put the put the food on the rake and
then I take it in and then if they give
me any lip I [ __ ] take their lights
out with the rake and get the [ __ ] off
my property that's crazy - well so what
are you guys a lot of you guys are not
able to make a living at all
it's good right huh I mean we know a lot
of comics who live paycheck to paycheck
yeah yeah no I know a lot of those guys
I saw them in Central Park eatin pigeons
oh there's nothing I can really do about
you know those guys I mean that's what
they want to do I mean they're putting
their stock in doing spots in New York
City and right when our people do a
podcast it's like well now you're eating
the vermin on the street because you
know I'm on patreon here making real
[ __ ] money and you're over there you
know telling me I'm not a good comment
cuz I you know wasn't passed the Comedy
Cellar well now how do me a favor eat a
[ __ ] raccoon turn because yeah
there's no nobody it's really hard for
most most of my peers right they're
happy making any money but thank God we
got podcast thank God for the patreon
you know and we're still able I'm still
able to make money and then I've lied on
a couple loan applications about gotten
some all loans that are illegal so
that's nice that's easy
and you have small business like you
haven't taken the selling your month yet
have you no I'm not selling my month yet
but I will absolutely do that if this
thing goes into the summer time I'm
absolutely down to sell my month
whatever what is uh what is your boy
saying is he saying they're gonna
stretch this into the summer cool
Governor Cuomo yeah yeah now that that's
the only Democrat that I'd ever bulb
farming that guy he's an Italian kid
that's just you know I mean there's
brothers his brother's a soccer mom Oh
Luke we got a deal with his brother
Chris Cuomo on CNN it's like you know
he's a martyr all of a sudden it's like
shut up and take your shirt off guy it's
like I don't know why you give the
broadcaster his shirt on nice when I
develop the TV all the time you know and
but Andrew Cuomo I think he's doing an
excellent job he [ __ ] Mayor Bill
DeBlasio instills a lot of fear yeah
Governor Cuomo says hey things are gonna
be okay here's and gives us the plan so
the governor though has said Connecticut
has just said today that they're gonna
open up May 20th and Governor Cuomo said
anything Connecticut or New Jersey does
that's what New York's gonna do we're
like all in solidarity so I'm hoping
that it opens it up at least phase one
opening May 20th all right yeah the only
thing como [ __ ] up well a few things
the one thing he really [ __ ] up on
when it was when cases started to pop up
especially the old folks home
he went if you're not showing symptoms
are you not really sick don't go the
hospital stayin the old folks home so
the most the deaths start in the old
folks home yeah story there's a lot of
people died for us it's it's all about
the subway it's like that's the only
difference between you know our city and
LA and Chicago and whatever it's just
the subway I mean at my daughter's
Godfather's an emergency room doctor and
he said especially in the beginning and
in late March early April and it was
like peak peak he said nearly 100% of
the patients that came in that were not
elderly that were in their 40s or 50s
they all took the subway and they all
that that was like the main carrier so
do they help you they all have maladies
like your lunch lady huh did they all
have bodies like a lunch lady
they all had lunch lady assets yeah well
that dude he told me he was like you
know the he's seeing the people who are
young who come in with corona and have
bad results they all got high blood
pressure
and [ __ ] fat asses and that's what I
got you got do you have high blood
pressure I do I got a little HBP but
it's only high blood pressure when and
like it cuz I get so nervous and worked
up that they'll take my blood pressure
will be through the roof
yeah but then as I calm down I just
watch you know like I watch videos i
watch like the you know the united
states winning the war in Vietnam and I
do things like that I'm down alright she
goes way down my god you say your your
baby you're still the [ __ ] enemy to me
Jenny see now again you're making this
about in Asia
you're making this Asian view Asia right
now and I and I have to stop you there
you just can't do that you're bringing
up Vietnam cats from she's Vietnamese
but she's American please be sensitive
please be sensitive to to the people
that work with us Sidra I'm sorry yeah
yeah yeah I'm [ __ ] yeah I guess when I
start my podcast up again I go to the
studio I'm just gonna hire a bunch of
Muslim women because they're already
wear the masks like it they think it's
been Corona since before Christ all
right well I don't know if that's true
either I don't think Corona is the
reason they wear these they wear their
they cover their faces god damn it
because please try to be a little more
sensitive to our ethnic brothers and
sisters out there we're once the [ __ ]
gold Birds on ABC about Jews so let's
all let's all you know that's all love
love each other
yeah absolutely I mean I'm staring right
at [ __ ] right at Brendan's and he's
got nice tight jeans on and he's got
just nice [ __ ] thigh lips well you
know what it is dude he's behind me
bikes he's a serious mountain biker now
he bikes home yeah and Brian you look
like a sphinx cat I like you I'm leaning
up and I've been working out I
appreciate that pal hey let's start off
with North Korea guys think kim
jeong-hoon is dead when I think he's
deader than a [ __ ] door now I don't
think yeah I think it's all [ __ ] you
think it's all [ __ ] yeah he's a five
wonder I wonder if he's [ __ ] dead or
not I don't know what is what are the
what is what is chin thick chin and cats
you guys think he's dead
we don't why are you asking them for
Christ you know my parents told me that
uh they saw this before back in the day
with his father Kim jong-un's father
yeah so he hid away for a while came
back later and I'm qincha parents age so
I know this Hey hey Kris what are you
watching right now in quarantine dude
give me something
um I started watching the last Kingdom
on Netflix I loved the Vikings I've been
watching the Vike I watch the Vikings on
the History Channel and I watch the last
King I'm watching the last Kingdom now I
watched all the Marvel movies in order I
watched unorthodox about a suit of
Jewish women that escapes I mean I
watched the first few episodes I thought
I thought it was Moshe kasher who's
playing the lead but it's some other
girl I watch that and then and then what
else
I mean Tiger King of course I watched
Tiger King I watched that too early and
then you know a bunch of Barbie [ __ ]
that my daughter wants to watch that's
pretty much it what about you guys I got
really into this show on Amazon hunters
with Al Pacino where they hunt Nazis in
New York in the 70s it's [ __ ] yeah it's
great but basically the bakery in my
neighborhood I grew up in Ridgewood
Queens and it's a old-school German
neighborhood and the bakery in my
neighborhoods been there since 1910 they
catered the sweets and desserts for the
biggest Nazi rally in America in 1938 at
Madison Square Garden they're the ones
that gave the freaking lives its hearts
and all the cookies to that oh wow yeah
are you still out there protesting I
know you're a champion of the Jews I
love did you I love to Jewish people I'm
circumcised myself I love Jewish people
they're actually getting in trouble in
Brooklyn because they're still going out
and having funerals and events almost
the corona of mire stuff so like I worry
that the anti-semitism is gonna it's
gonna like you know topple because it
sucks cuz it's like I don't know I mean
I try to do it's like it's like you know
for me it's like these people like fine
whatever they want to do is is up to
them I just go I Drive by if I ever see
like Orthodox funeral eyes drop I'll
just throw ham and cheese sandwiches
happen and then they use very well okay
see again I think that's a very racist
thing to do and here how is that racist
well you're acting is that you're
throwing pork at very religious people
and I think that would be offensive to
Muslims Jews and frankly to me as well
just because you don't be throwing ham
and cheese you threw it ham and cheese
sandwich at me I would try to flag you
down and punch you in the face I'm just
saying again I have my hands full I have
my hands full you're a big sturdy kid
yeah it's just it works two ways what I
do is I Drive around with the cooler
full of ham and cheese sandwiches and a
go I break up
I break up any Hasidic Jewish funerals
or events that are going on because I
don't want them to get sick from Corona
I want to put their masks on so I draw
that and then I continue driving it to
my head and I throw ham and cheese
outside the comedy clubs and all the
comedians come out and scurry off the
steps and I can see them because ham
cheese and squab or raccoon goes well
with it goes well Chris have you seen
what's going on on out here in LA
there's straight-up protests like at the
beach and stuff what because people want
to you're saying Juana the lockdown it
be over Heather yeah California it's
[ __ ] at done with it man well I get
it because it's like you guys really you
know based off your population don't
really have that many cases and deaths I
think your governor did a great job of
closing down the state early enough and
control what he can control so we kind
of feel I get I get if I was living in
California I'd be like you know it feels
like the problems happening 3,000 miles
away which you know kind of is but then
I understand how it can spread very
rapidly you guys are doing better like
yeah like even coma came out and said
that you guys peaked a while ago it's
going there's no joy in New York there's
really no choice I mean you can't you
know I mean it got flow I mean there's
people there's bodies in the back of
u-haul trucks outside funeral homes so
you can't really there's no other choice
here I think even now though I've
noticed like over the past like two or
three weeks like you'll see people come
out more and more and more without masks
without gloves you're starting to see
people walking around more I mean in
late March I mean on my corner there
were like army trucks driving up and
down the blocks all that it's not that I
shake hands and hug oh you were here
right now fine I would lick your [ __ ]
face Chris I don't give up funny how
it's becoming like it's a form of
defiance like I don't get to talk about
karana come over here I'm not gonna
change my I'm not going to change my
behavior in my life in a sort of like
people get are so wary of it sure well
yeah I mean yesterday I went to the
doctor's office oh my god an antibody
past the corona antibody test because I
was like I'm sure I've gotten it even if
I didn't have symptoms and it was a
negative it was a negative test was one
of the only times I got a negative test
and was happy about it I understand yeah
but I still got a drip baby are you
writing are you
who are you writing right now are you
writing what'd you say honey bubbles no
no don't call me that
don't call me honey bobbles don't man
I'm not comfortable with honey bubbles
now what about tortellini - if she like
that all like tortellini porcini that's
- no no I don't like these things you
have to call me Brian
why do I like you got a nice little
shaped head I mean you're [ __ ] you
look good baby got a nice little pump
yeah I got a pump I do all right I mean
I trained I trained I know days off you
know what I'm saying no dude yeah
absolutely so what what you say chicken
no you can't call you a chicken you're
objectifying man and it's everyone
nature Christa you're honest you guys
get together and do the podcast or you
guys he does it from the house from
there no because he honest is our wife
is pregnant now she's I think about four
months pregnant now so you know you
can't there research is not you know you
don't want to go around a pregnant woman
who knows what happens you know in the
early stages of gestation like that so
we don't we just do it you know over
zoom just like this and that's just I
mean really besides my family I mean I
haven't seen anybody and that's most of
your people we haven't seen each other
since you know March 12th or something
like that because it's just too risky
that's crazy guy who would have seen
this coming these no knowings nobody I
mean I mean not none of us we're all
making jokes about it like people are
posting jut like four to come the last
days at the Comedy Cellar we'll all just
like posting jokes about you know
coronavirus and how it's you know not
Seattle's problem or China's problem and
then literally three days later the
streets are closed so it came up on as
quick but I think the good news is is
that they keep talking about the second
wave doctor foul Qi little sweet doctor
doctor how she thought she keeps talking
about the second way and I and I think
we're gonna be so much more well
prepared for it now because we're taking
it seriously because the first one that
little squeak got on and started telling
us about the corona virus we're like
where's this guy's [ __ ] stepstool who
is this guy I want to take him my duffel
bag I mean I was I you know I was
watching this this this little squeak
doctor come on I'm like it's just one of
my daughter's classmates I mean who the
[ __ ] it's it's guys the squeak it does a
little baby guy yelling at us but now I
really listen to him and I'm a disciple
of dr. fountain okay cuz I oh wow yeah
my only criticism for foul cheese he
never comes up with
he never has any ideas or a plan just me
and he likes to exaggerate he likes to
say things like you know a lot of people
like maybe maybe 300,000 they said what
do you think and what do you think of
this what do you think of this because
I'm just trying to think you know you
guys are Hollywood I'm trying to think
Hollywood my so where you think of this
we get the movie that comes out pandemic
2020 who gets two years we fund that we
got doctor foul food we got him played
by Joe Pesci
we got Martin Scorsese directing it we
got Donald Trump we'll have him play by
Alec Baldwin and then for the
coronavirus I was thinking we have that
play by Bobby Lee what do you think hold
on do it again I mean I don't think I
don't want Bobby Lee die again I'm
taking a fence a little bit because both
of these Korean he's really American and
you want him to play a virus I mean I
want to get this Chris now because I
just because the virus they say it's a
little virus and I you know he's shorter
guy no no patient zero me know yet maybe
pickles on stage nope no bills on time I
don't like this I don't like this movie
what about Ronny Chang um nope see it
again here no but there's you're you're
focusing on the wrong thing I'm saying
I'm saying funny comedians that that
kill you know to play the crud about her
so Bobby Lee or Ronny Chang or Margaret
Cho no there's no I'm just no tonight
you're it's a woman okay she's a woman
you're talking about all of these people
are Korean I have a gang again and
you're lumping in Koreans with Chinese I
already find that offensive and I'm
gonna have to ask you to to maybe maybe
suggest a white guy to play the virus
just on clues I would say quarantines
made him a little racist but he was like
this before here because turn you now a
bit of a racist I'm just kidding around
I hope the fans I'm just kidding as I
said at the first time I'm the one of
the bigger I have the biggest
transgender fan base from any podcast
and now we tried it we tried to verify
that Chris and we really couldn't see
any hard to find stats on that right
stats on that dude cuz I got a [ __ ]
month I just showed you you don't think
you don't think that my pants are your
pants still down my yeah they're always
yeah you're in your daughter's room
she's four and you don't have the
decency to wear pants Chris I mean
whatever Barba does in my ass right now
it matter now that that spreads that's
breads kovat or pink a well or allegedly
pink I think I know I'm just I'm just
kidding around yeah no quarantine I've
been cooped up Chrissy but I you know
yeah I'm just it's like one of these
things where it's like you know you try
to do comedy over this film and then
sometimes it doesn't connect and then
you just look like really alright so
sorry
that's a virus Chris it might be your
behavior for Christ I'm just kidding no
guys I'm obviously I'm just kidding I
hope everyone's alright I know we loved
one stay safe and Nancy Pelosi created
the corona virus you can't convince me
otherwise
it's very insignia signing off on a nice
note I mean yeah how about giving us
something positive before you leave with
some positive me here's a positive note
it's Friday
you know it's Friday it's give us some
hope Friday saying you might be guest of
the year man Wow that's [ __ ] crazy I
know I really appreciate that night
hopefully hopefully it's me but yes
something positive I mean I got you know
I'm trying to bring the laughter on
every day like I said we got that
morning show wet by in the morning for a
spanish-speaking audience we do the show
in English so you know but this webpart
Spanish but that's on patreon.com so
hold on it's a spit you're saying it's a
Spanish show but you do it in English so
I'm not sure this because you call it
without a tinsmith yeah what slip up me
speaking well I don't know what it means
but it's weapon in the morning or if
you're watching with your kids what Beto
in the morning do you speak Spanish
Chris I don't speak Spanish but you know
along with the transgender fan base we
also have we learned that we also have
one of the biggest Spanish speaking fan
bases out there so we said to give back
to them we're gonna do a morning show in
Spanish about Tom Segura does a podcast
in Spanish 3 so we need to do that too
following Tom Segura footsteps so we
made the morning show which is available
on patreon.com slash marriage boys Wepa
in the morning what it is in English and
that day can translate to Spanish in
their homes because this is the red wine
we speak English language's Christmas oh
man it's funny you can get crisps that's
inclusive we can you because we have a
diverse audience could you be a little
more inclusive with your message well
dami Moscow Salina
will be more inclusive with with the map
with my message I just want to say yeah
I hope um I hope everyone out there is
listening to the rules socially
distancing six feet apart we're all
gonna get through this together getting
your mask on get your gloves on keep
your ass clean
you know there's virus it is not China's
fault Chinese Americans have nothing to
do with this do not take anything out on
them on Asian people they have nothing
to do with this we're all in this
together but you know as long as you're
going outside with the American flag
wrapped around you at the plank blasting
Bruce Springsteen I think you're fine
okay now that's again Lady America yeah
it's pretty American it's pretty
American does it have to be Springsteen
that's pretty no it doesn't have to be
Springsteen it it doesn't have to be
Bruce Springsteen at all you can just
you can people you can play the national
anthem whatever you guys want what about
a little Metallica it's pretty America
there you go metallica metallica is good
whoever you want whoever whatever you
want to do but listen we're all we're
all in this together but you know if
this is really I mean it's New York
City's problem right I mean I know other
states are trying to jump in and be like
yeah where we have cases to shut up okay
bring your stuff to New York we're all
[ __ ] dying here and it's just pretty
bad okay I mean I'd cut my dick off and
sold it on the streets and give my
family something to eat tonight so this
I mean I don't care about what your
problems are I will shut up and give us
your money
Jesus Christ man DC panic that these
must be bad it must be very bad to staff
no you you have been using your dick
much huh or have you been well no I
haven't been Brendan what's in that cup
is that your urine I'd like to I'd like
to purchase that oh it's whiskey buddy
brand drinks in the middle of the day oh
where did dude I gotta be on this one
I've been becoming like a full-fledged
alcoholic with myself I mean every day
I'm drinking Pinot Grigios and beers I'm
doing everything I did crystal meth the
other night all right scatting what
no I know because I'm just sitting
inside it's like what am I supposed to
do you know I don't just do anything
what time it isn't glue time what time
does the baby girl go to sleep what
times before you go to sleep 7:00 so
yeah I mean quarantine with the
four-year-old it's rough Bubba's it's a
little brutes Macoutes even though she's
my best friend I love her so much I mean
she's you know we're past the stages
with naps so she doesn't see naps
anymore
Papa's okay no she wakes up every day
7:30 in the morning she goes to bed 9 10
o'clock at night and it's a hundred
miles an hour all day every day but you
know the silver lining is I'm spending
so much time at there you know all this
time that I would have been on the road
and all that I'm with her so it's
beautiful and that even that lets you
know a little inside Kombi I don't know
how you guys feel about this but this
whole pandemic in quarantine has been
making me rethink the road it's like do
I want to go to some city to sit there
for four days and deal with whatever
[ __ ] deal a comedy club wants to
give when I can be you know doing the
podcast making money and taking care of
my own family not missing things with my
daughter yeah it's made me rethink
career stuff a little yeah yeah I think
anybody who doesn't grow from this
lockdown is a [ __ ] [ __ ] anybody who
doesn't reconsider things and kind of
take things into perspective I mean what
are you doing man yeah yeah no I know
I've been growling I've been doing a lot
of you know I've been reading a lot of
been reading I'm reading a book on John
Adams right now I was write a book on
the Civil War been reading a lot about
that over a lot about the history and
about how Chinese been controlling us
for a long time and it's just about over
okay well reading those books okay well
no China hasn't been a very fair player
but all right no no I know I know but
I've been reading I've been reading this
book on John Adams it's fantastic it's
uh he was I didn't know that he was the
lawyer that represented the British
soldiers for the Boston Massacre did you
guys know I didn't know that I didn't
know I didn't know that actually I think
I did I read that once there you go
what um you guys went you're lying a lot
today that's not true
yeah boy say Brian's been lying a little
bit today why you lying bro I ever read
that book tell me he told me he's been
going on hikes then when we realized
that he's lying cos Courtney said woman
the last time you weren't I and I said
he said three days ago second I said
four days ago and then
turns out it was probably close to six
weeks ago those trails are shut down
this yeah but that's that's an honest
mistake right because sometimes you're
like because what happens is the days
all blend in as one so he said I got
caught in a lie I said four days maybe
I'm a Papa then you just told him you
read that book but then you never did no
no I didn't read that book but I read
that it was a lawyer for the Boston for
the for the boss of millennion okay but
wait baby gorgeous have you been working
out
I haven't I trained hard he's a bit he's
a bit of tummy right now though I know
it doesn't you both you guys look like
you're in fantastic [ __ ] you really look
like they're in fantastic shape he's
been eating a little late at night I've
been eating late at night I don't know
it drugs - I don't some drugs - I did a
tour monkey would you wanna hang I mean
do you want out what do you David seen
your kids you want to hang out I mean
what do you want to do you want me to
talk cross countries no it's all good I
am hanging with my kids but it's no need
I mean whatever you got your daughter
and everything else so that's fine yeah
dude I mean literally man to protect
myself I've been sticking Clorox wipes
up my ass like the president said and I
don't have okay well good you as soon as
this corona bullshit's over you're
flying to LA and coming on the show in
the house hunt dude I'd love to come on
the show in house 100% I mean I know
sometimes on the zoom I mean it's hard
to get a feel but you know he goes okay
don't throw ham and cheese at anybody
I'm just [ __ ] joking over here in my
door I'm in my I'm locked in my
daughter's bedroom I'm kidding around
and butcher daughter doing right now
what what's your daughter doing right
now
I think she's outside I think she's
outside in the street okay well who's
watching her for this one in the streets
well nobody's but I mean who's ready to
defend the house against I mean if
there's Asians coming around what am I
supposed to do no you can't Chris you're
turning into anti-asian podcast this is
really out of control here of our Asian
listeners were American forgotten guy
you're out there dressed like Mad Max
with a [ __ ] potato gun slide it looks
Chinese fire a baked potato
your child for kidding I'm kidding I
loved I love to Chinese I love everyone
I truly this coronavirus you know it
sucks right now but I think it's getting
better all the babies in the room it's
getting better and I've just sitting
around I love everybody
all right well fine I do fine we see the
baby no no way
all right all right now she ran out she
ran out all right dude what we love you
man
love you crazy bodies coming honest well
done sir thank you guys love you guys
stay for having me my little brother I
can't buy gen buy this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]